we here at United understand that  sometimes flying can be a real hassle  which is why we're proud to introduce  United ground lines a new more  down-to-earth way of traveling it's easy  just buy your ticket with our app and  get dragged to your destination zero  feet expected arrival time of Chicago 28  days good low low fares and a low low  altitude United ground Lines provides  all the same perks you get with air  travel snacks in-flight shopping can I  get the serenity pot for cats courteous  pilots and if you look to your right you  will see the Grand Canyon oh it's just  like flying in every way with hubs all  over the US there's no place we can't  drag you to you'll arrive at your  destination in a matter of many days  well I hope you enjoyed your drag time  for me to go back to Los Angeles oh  thanks fellas  United grown lines drag the friendly  ground  [Applause]  you